so this is a story from fox news this is
where were we new jersey gym co-owner
says state seized legal defense funds
amid battle over coveted fines
quote we had no money in our bank
account ian smith tells tucker carlson
tonight
well i don't need to read this but i
will mention 173
613 stolen by governor phil murphy
and his cronies but ian's here so dude
what happened
so uh just a regular day you know
opening our gym frank my partner checked
the bank account
and um i believe it was thursday morning
and it was bone dry down to the very
last penny
was it was there was there literally
like no zero zero dollars
um ever they took everything um and
next to it it had a you know a
transaction
for new jersey state execution you know
so
for the total amount for everything that
was in the bank account
but like how did they know what to
request or did they just say
give us the cash i'm pretty sure they
just called santan uh santander bank and
said
you're going to empty this bank account
now and they said sure and then
did they tell you why they did it no
we've got no explanation from anybody
all right so let's so let's let's break
down the story real quick um from the
beginning
you guys were locked down like everybody
else and then one day
you opened back up and the governor was
like nah none of that so what happened
uh so about seven weeks into the
lockdown frank and i decided that we
were gonna reopen
we were going to do so publicly not not
because
we wanted the attention but because we
wanted to present a plan to the public
where all small businesses could use the
same measures that we had
adapted to their own business we were
looking around i think like most people
had started to at that point and saying
a lot of this doesn't make sense you
know the fact that all of these small
businesses are
villainized and deemed as unsafe but you
can slap a mask on your face and wipe
your cart down and go have a frenzy in
walmart
just wasn't really making sense so we
said okay we're going to devise our own
safety plan we went above and beyond
we went so far as to get hydroxyl
generators
which convert humidity in the air to
oh molecules runs uh 33 000 cubic square
feet
per per minute circulating air i mean we
we did everything we possibly could to
the point where if they told us we
couldn't open it would be absurd
um and then we opened and
we were met with the heavy hand of
government on day one
and that just continued to escalate to
the point where
now eight months into it we have over 80
criminal and municipal charges
we've had our business license stripped
we've had a health department shut down
we've had our locks physically changed
we've had our
doors boarded up we've been arrested uh
we're fined 15
497.76 per day for every day that we're
in operation
which was originally a
fine for being open and then once gyms
were allowed to be opened
they the attorney general called us and
said you need to mandate masks
and we said no we're going to make them
optional because while working out it's
not really a
smart thing to have your face covered um
and it even says
in the executive order in new jersey
that opened sports
that you shouldn't wear it during
intense aerobic and anaerobic
that's that's the government's actual
recommendation that's the government's
recommendation in the
executive order that opened indoor
sports yeah they said it's dangerous to
wear but in the executive order that
opened gyms
they said cloth face coverings are
required which
is just like the government makes no
sense you know it's
it's not surprising at all so so i guess
what i wanted to get to starting from
the beginning is some some people have
already you know commented in the chat
that
that money that was taken wasn't stolen
it was a fine you owed the government
right
sure sure it was a an unconstitutional
and oppressive fine
the laws when it comes to finding
businesses
i think the exact word they use is it
should be a punitive sting
and finding a small business that has
only been open for less than two years
fifteen thousand four hundred ninety
seven dollars 76 cents per day is not a
punitive sting that's a death blow
um even one day yeah exactly even one
day i mean
our our membership revenue is
not that that barely covers a month of
of
memberships a month you know it just
it's it's so out of proportion
that um those fines are unconstitutional
so we've been fighting them ever since
we're in the appeals process
so yes we are fine absolutely you know
people are right when they say
you know you're being fined correct but
the the process is not concluded yet so
you're actually
this is your legal defense fund you're
in court in court
it's active litigation in four different
matters and so before there was any
resolution
they drained your accounts yep so so
here's my question was this account
an existing account you had or was it
new and set up for legal defense
this is an existing business account but
the money comes almost entirely from our
gofundme account
which is where people donate either
locally because we don't charge for
we don't charge members we haven't
charged our members since april 1st
um first of all we didn't we didn't
charge because we weren't allowed to be
open so we said
we're just open you know we weren't we
weren't in it for the money we were in
it to
to win a legal battle but then after
they stripped our business license
obviously
we can't charge so we haven't charged
it's all donations and then it's t-shirt
sales
do you own the building we do not but
our landlord is very accommodating
ah very accommodating yeah i wondered
about that because there's other
businesses too who have you know defied
lockdown and things like that in various
areas
and i wonder what the landlords are
probably thinking or you know i wonder
if the government's gone to them
but i want to get to the most
interesting uh aspect outside of this so
first i just want to make sure we stress
that was the legal defense fund for
paying your lawyers to challenge the
fines in the first place
and they went and they took your ability
to defend yourself that's crazy but let
me tell you
you know i think the craziest thing is
and you can elaborate on this so i
actually
i used to live right by your gym like
maybe like i think only like three and a
half four miles away and we we cruised
over a couple times and talked to some
of the locals
you weren't there i'm not sure you know
what happened but you know you guys had
like the 14th amendment written and put
up on the windows and stuff
so uh we went there after it was
announced that your gym had been flooded
yeah and so we talked to some locals who
told us something really crazy
that someone stuffed paper towels into a
it's like a sewage line
a vent or something in the back causing
a backup and that's this is what someone
told me so tell me
tell me if this is true or not someone
there said that the previous
day just before the flooding happened
there were two squad cars blocking the
alleyway behind
both the entrance and the both entrances
to the alleyway so there's like a single
stretch that goes behind
this complex and they said that two
squad cars were like blocking the road
and the cops said you can't come back
here go away next thing they knew
someone back there jammed it full of
paper towels and flooded the whole
building there was also a
barrow of belmar water truck back there
too really yes
so wait wait dude coincidentally
coincidentally and that was that was one
of
seven times it happened i think i think
when you guys were there it was actually
the first time yeah the first time we've
had seven sabotages in total
what all the same thing like jamming
paper towels or what
the the building is is pretty old so
whoever is doing it and and i i
i do not claim to know who but it's
definitely intentional we've had
multiple plumbing crews come out and say
this isn't i mean this isn't you know
somebody took a big dump and and
you know had too much toilet paper this
is this is a very intentional act
whoever's doing it
understands that we have a very old
system
and what they're doing is is
manipulating
just a crappy old plumbing system so it
takes somebody who knows what they're
doing
so and just to clarify you did you
witness a a
water truck and police cars blocking
that area we had pictures of it yeah
so i didn't i didn't personally witness
it but i had pictures sent in
around that time that we reopened we had
so many eyes and ears on the place just
because people were so
invested in our story and invested in
what we were doing that
there were people sleeping out in the
parking lot during the opening nights
there were people kind of surveilling
the place
sending us pictures videos the whole
night is it possible that the
the the good hearted police were
guarding the water truck trying to
save your business from the flooding i
mean the water truck came out to try and
make sure you know
oh no it's gonna flood we gotta save
this guy it's it's hard to imagine they
would be doing anything else but that
well
[Laughter]
i was going going to ask you how's your
relationship with the police there
because wasn't there
one viral video of an officer refusing
to kind of
go through with the order so so how has
that been
can you explain to people what happened
and your relationship with them yeah
absolutely i mean we
we notified the police we were going to
open we notified the mayor everybody so
and and that was because we didn't we
don't want to blindside anybody we knew
a lot of people were going to show up
and we didn't want to
to put the town in in a difficult
position any more of a difficult
position than we were putting it in
um so that video was actually from day
one at right about 12 o'clock
they they walked up and that was the now
retired police chief or
captain captain excuse me retired now
yes retired
he was um apparently he was on his way
out and he was done with the bs anyway
um but yeah he came up and he said
you're all in violation of an executive
order and he took a nice long dramatic
pause and he said on that note everybody
have a nice day
yeah and it was funny because back then
we were like yes we won we did it we did
it
and yeah governor murphy saw that video
and
15 minutes later the attorney general
gerber gual
called the camden county prosecutor um
or excuse me the county county
yeah kenny had prosecutor who then
called the belmar police department and
said if you do not get in there and take
action
we are going to furlough the entire
belmar police department for
60 days yes that was and so and so the
spineless bellmar cops came in so the
second lieutenant who is definitely
uh definitely a bootlicker he was he was
anxious to please father murphy
um and came up and handed us our first
of
80 summons wow wow first so uh before
he showed up and issued the summons did
he go to murphy's house to lick his feet
out of all the out of all the belmar so
we have a great relationship with the
belmar pd
most of them before covid were members
of our gym oh cool you know belmar and
you're familiar with the area you know
it's
it's a local blue-collar kind of
middle-class area so our gym is full of
these kind of people they're full of
cops firefighters
um you know active and veteran military
um and it's a shame because they were
put in a bad
very bad position most of them didn't
want to be there from
the start and then as it started to
escalate
they were forced to do things that they
didn't want to do i disagree yeah well
correct me if i'm wrong weren't people
arrested uh
for just attending your gym as well one
person was
several people were cited though and fun
fact
all of those citations are the only
still
existing coveted citations for any
protesting during that time wow
all other charges have been dropped
except any regarding
what are they going to charge for or
what do they get violation of a
governor's orders which is this
archaic statute from like 1890 something
you sure didn't
they didn't say decree that's why i say
i disagree
cause i remember watching this video
where i'm not sure if it was you or
somebody was saying you look the cops
are doing their jobs
they're being forced to do this nah i
think any one of those cops could have
been like nah
and then and then it would have been
done they wouldn't have gotten rid of
the police
they wouldn't have further department if
every single officer said do it furlough
us
and then when you start getting phone
calls and they call for your head
you come knocking give us a raise
whatever i've seen it happen in numerous
protests
you're you're right you're right but
cops didn't take it would take that one
person
to say no and then it would take the
other people to get up on the dance
floor with them and
fortunately that doesn't happen but i
agree with you 100 percent if we had
uh you know we've had too many good
times uh this this this past
several decades have been good times all
around and you know what i think
i see in my opinion what's going on is
these cops
many of them can see the suffering that
you that your your customers that your
business the local business are going
through
and they can see the suffering of the
middle class blue-collar worker who
can't feed his kids anymore and
they think i don't want to be like them
i'm getting a paycheck
so i'll lick the boot of whoever it
takes if i get my paycheck so then
you know the problem i see is and with
all due respect
when people say well they have no choice
they do it's a job
they could say i will not oppress my
community
for a paycheck and if if at once
one person two people if all of these
regular
regular guys who were in the department
just said you're not going to get me to
do it because i go to that gym
they're going to get mad at me i'm not
going to be able to go out for beers
with anybody anymore then they'd be like
sorry governor we can't do it
you're going to bring in cops from a
different city because these guys won't
do it instead
they just say sure whatever and then
they get the other problem is
there's no penalty for the cops who
violate constitutional rights of
individuals
the first amendment doesn't doesn't have
their caveats
it doesn't right we have a right to
assemble for whatever reason
ian let's go assemble to uh play magic
the gathering okay there's no the the
first amendment doesn't say anything
about why you can assemble just that
just the right yeah all it takes is for
those cops to say i won't violate the
constitutional rights of these
individuals
and then it would not happen more than
that the problem is i don't think a lot
of them are educated on that
i don't i don't think when they sign up
for the job these days and and that's
that that doesn't excuse them by any by
any means but i don't even think that's
stressed anymore in the police academy i
don't think
you know you know you know what i think
i think you guys are too good of people
yeah i think that's really it i think
you're you're respectful and nice to
these guys because you know
you don't want those cops to be out of
work you don't you want you want
everybody able to work feed their
families
and so you give them the respect they
don't return and so long as the
community isn't willing to
like you know what you need you need
like uh what what did jorge say
what's the what's the slipper called
that the the mom
yeah he was talking about how like you
know what happens if you go against you
know
they they hit you with the little
slipper you need you need something like
uh like a grandma to be like young man
what are you doing and have them be like
listen
it's not okay what you're doing to these
people but so long as the community says
thank you officer we respect what you're
doing they'll keep doing it
if you guys said you do this you're
never welcome here again they think
twice
you're starting i think you're starting
to actually see that you're starting to
see the cops
now get a lot of pressure from the right
as frustration
tends to mount i think in the beginning
of this it was the
you know especially the right tends to
be the the thin blue line crowd yeah you
know what i mean and not anymore
and and it that definitely seems to be
at least wavering a little bit you know
because people are getting more and more
frustrated
and they're saying you know they've
tried everything they're opening their
business they're doing
you know they're they're trying to live
their lives they're trying to just
not be bothered and we're eight months
in
and there's still police officers who
are going along with it so people are
you you're starting to get that
sentiment where people are getting a lot
less forgiving about
oh you're just following orders i mean i
think you're going to see more of it
you talked about some of these officers
being ignorant but i know a lot of
police officers that i
that i always say not knowing the law is
not an excuse for not following
it and and and they need to really
understand here this is so
counterintuitive we have these decrees
by a goldman sachs executive who is now
governor
that is telling you no gym no small
businesses
no working out no bettering yourself
meanwhile walmart liquor stores all of
them perfectly fine
but you're talking about you're in the
business of making people healthy
right you're in the business of making
people work out me and lydia just
started lifting literally like a week
ago
only once we're already hooked and
addicted to it because you feel
very good it feels amazing but but but i
i
you know and and that's something that
people are deprived of
because of a goldman sachs executive
saying i know what's better for you and
they don't because if they did
they would have been talking about diet
nutrition sleep exercise
almost everything the opposite is so so
so what you brought up is something very
important
uh these officers need to know that
they're part of a larger problem
that they need to realize and they need
family and friends to come together and
shame them for from doing the wrong
thing and following people who
are doing bad things i i agree but i'll
push back a little bit i don't like the
shaming thing
it's like a very left-wing thing where
they like chant shame
no you wanted a change
i'm talking about someone's grandma
bopping them on the head
lightly being like how dare you a
well-placed jungler will hurt yes
i'm not saying beat your kids i'm saying
they got some guys in his late 20s early
30s and his grandma's like what did you
do are you nuts and then have him be
like okay
well that's what i mean i agree with you
on that point but you need more of that
the problem i see is there have been
these stories of like
leftist cafes where a cop will come in
and they'll be like get out we don't
serve your kind around here no cops
and the cops are like dude what i think
that's crazy
you know if it's it's like dude we i i
we need police you know i think i think
it was brett weinstein who said
uh you know a civilized society requires
the police to be able to arrest people
okay and sometimes they make mistakes
and there are heirs we have to sort
through those things
i think when police brutality happens
it's horrible it needs to be stopped i
think when police abuse their power we
got to call it out and we need some
police reform because there's issues
where
i've seen i've seen way too many
examples of cops not being held
accountable
but i think it's insane if you go around
saying all cops are bad or whatever and
you know
to uh to my good friend michael malus i
mostly disagree
he says he said all cops are criminals
i've actually heard him re
uh what's the word uh recalibrate that
recalibrate yes that's one way to phrase
it
uh that wasn't what i was going to say
like on the show yeah he was saying
they're not all they're not all horrible
people i i was surprised to hear him say
because
because we had this conversation and my
thing is like there's a problem with the
culture there's a problem with people
freezing to hold them accountable
and you know for a long time i think
because the left
irrationally attacked cops with all the
riots especially
watching watching the minneapolis police
department be burned down and the cops
running for their lives as like
riders are storming the building and
torching it and then you have in
portland where they barricaded the front
and back
so there was no way out and tried
burning the building down people inside
of it
i can sympathize with those officers
like dude that's crazy yeah i don't like
getting tickets either
you know but it's like come on man you
don't burn a building with people inside
it because you're mad they're giving
fines people they have quotas
but then the issue is because of that i
see a lot of conservatives who are
defensive of police who will say they're
just overly so
right exactly so now it's now it's
changing though they threw the blue
lives
the thin blue line flag on the ground
and stomped on it you know yeah i mean i
i've been speaking in dc you know for
all these these past events and stuff
bringing in the small business aspect
and you're starting to see especially dc
at night when
when antifa and the proud boys tend to
go at it you know
um neither side is very appreciative of
the cops being there you know you're
you have the the leftist chant you know
that um
that all cops are are bad and then and
then you have
basically the right side saying you know
why are you protecting these people let
us take care of it or you know
and and why are you defending the you
know
the antifa you know why why are you why
are you holding us back and they're
they're getting increasingly frustrated
and i don't see it going anywhere
except in that same direction in a
downward spiral where
they're going to be pitted between
everybody i you know
i i think it's it's there's a lot of
tribalism here
and i think you know like like we were
just saying you know a lot of a lot of
people on the right were very defensive
of cops
it was a cold wake-up call when the
conservatives were the ones getting
arrested
and smacked down you know
i've seen a lot of peaceful legitimate
leftist protests i like how they say you
know like 93
of all the protests were peaceful and
it's like okay okay i get it no but
there there were a lot
in my day i've seen peaceful protests
i've seen the cops strike first
i've seen you know a cop walk up to a
crowd of people in ferguson and throw a
flashbang at him for no reason
there was no order there was no nobody
cared and they just started this and all
sudden boom everyone went crazy and
people were running and screaming and
then looters started looting in the
chaos
and i'm like why would they do that and
there's no accountability for that stuff
but
you're seeing that i say the logical
solution is well we need some reform
like we need to be able to call that out
journalists should film that guy there
should be video of it
instead we get a very extremist left
view that all cops everywhere always are
bad
burn down all the building which is
insane and then on the right you get
this overwhelming forgiveness
i'm worried about what's gonna happen
when police have no support and we
actually get a defund the police
movement that has no resistance
because i can't see conservatives being
like i'm gonna keep sticking up for
these people after my business was
destroyed
you know eventually the last time you're
gonna you're gonna lose support from
every side and then these same
politicians who have been chanting
defund the police are gonna have
absolutely no opposition to it because
all rational thinking is just gonna go
out the window because everybody's
emotional at that point
and then the politicians are going to do
what they do best and take advantage of
a situation
where people are pitted against each
other and they get to do whatever they
want to do anyway you see what happened
in minneapolis after they voted to
defund the police
yeah prime skyrockets crime skyrocketed
and they i think they actually had to do
a study as to figure out why
they started getting a bunch of phone
calls from angry constituents
saying why are people shooting outside
my eyes why is crime skyrocketing
and they and they ran back in and said
can we take this back and bring the
police back
they already lost a ton of officers who
quit because they were like you don't
support us we're getting out of here you
know we're done
and so now crime remains very high crime
is high across the board
but the cops that stayed they stayed
because they still had support
i can't imagine at this point i mean you
got to be crazy look at what happened in
new york city
you got to be crazy to live in new york
and support the police i'm sorry man
maybe maybe upstate new york but in new
york city the mayor
without any approval pla painted a
political slogan in the street
got a bunch of nypd to protect it and
actually arrest those who opposed it
and now they're lining up in front of
bars blocking people from walking into a
building doing something similar to what
you guys did opening you know but not
selling stuff doing donations yeah i was
at i was at max public house
you went check it out yeah i was there i
actually i spoke there and went up to
show my support to danny and them and
they had 20 those were sheriffs there's
uh they're basically
uh cuomo's personal guard i mean
seriously because
he had at that point he had lost the
support of the nypd there was nypd
driving by honking their horns
they were driving up the street honking
their horns in support i could support
that um
which i thought was pretty cool but yeah
that was the sheriffs who were doing
that that day
yeah um but they i mean that's exactly
what they were they were there to
enforce his personal will
that's what it is there's no there's no
statutory law by which he can do this
in fact it flies in the face of the
constitution and every time him
murphy whitmer you know wolf when they
do these things and then lose in the
courts they just
well i'll do another one and that's it
snap their fingers
okay oh oh it's that you sued and now my
executive order has been you know
rescinded
here's a new executive order slightly
different or they just come at you with
another public institution they'll bring
in the health department they'll bring
in the zoning department
you know and they just move right onto
the next thing cuomo lost the support of
the nypd so he shifted to the
to the sheriffs newsom lost the the
support of the sheriff so he went with
the health department
health department he can control very
easily thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show live
monday through friday at 8 pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time